[Music]  I've never been proposed to I've never  been engaged so I take this very  seriously and as much as I love your son  there's a lot of things that I want to  talk about with Nik before the actual  proposal date I am now in the position  that Nick was in twice yeah  and it's scary I'm sure it is now do you  think that the fact that we at least I  love him  mmm and I feel like he is at that point  or almost at that point I'm not sure I'm  assuming do you think that love is  enough to make a relationship last you  have to not just love the person but you  have to be willing to give up you have  to sacrifice so no no it's not enough  it's commitment it's selflessness  [Music]  just never if that wasn't me to meet  anyone like I really could feel  promotion but there was a little bit of  fear that she would hurt Nick my only  concern is that he would get rejected  again  you  [Music]